great passing that was sick what hand ey
coordination by the moov folks you are
witnessing magic as on the attack to m m he
scores and the head Cera ready down and ball
Arena M Ron makes such a great pass and then mck
instead of just doing the quick shot he dangles
and slides to the back head and just Buri this
watch him grab it a little dust backhanded shell
no chance he wasn't getting that Hatty Nathan
K has been Unstoppable what a play and zanim
will move it ahe of forer Forster gets away from
wildon cuts to the middle of the shiny St what
stands out in this goal is a strength by Forster
protect the puck while the spoon bounces off of
Forester and then the skill can come into play
the drag the shot and it goes right through the
legs ofart a real determined effort from Forester
there crossing the blue line Pinto to the ne tto
and he scores jeane Pinto there's your overtime
winner teraso gives it to shabbat Shabbat gets
Pinto driving to the net and it's just a little
shovel pass it's a placement pass I'll lay it into
a spot and I'll let Pinto do the rest he skates
into it all he does is change the direction and
it catches Lion on the stick side post it in
brunovich pickpocketed by Bor strad he's got
Tolen in another has what a play outstanding
Tick Tac goal it doesn't get any better than
this look at this passing play the two on0 in
front of the N after the steal by Oliver bork
strand he gets his Puck to K it back to Gord and
Ellie buries it into the back of the net and now
brunovich Quick Pass for Kyu to the middle buich
for Thomas what a pass another pass tyy right down
Broadway he scores great passing that was sick
pav bich had it Prime real estate passes it over
to Thomas what a play by Scott perunovic just
redirects it to Jordan Kyu who makes no mistake
what a passing Play All Around Scott perunovic
with that nice soft touch leaving it for Kyu
finds the back of the net Here Comes McKinnon
again the ab on side tan Dr it that's to Mo
Bing stay wi oh my goodness trck it DS out
it in front what hand ey coordination by the
moov I mean that was a back cander out of
midair flipped in by Reds and wow that was
magnificent Kings win the draw dowy spinning
he's had a hot hand lately hands It Off K down
to the circle a shot score great move by dowy
but watch this Puck is outside it's inside he
moves up and then he shoots back against
the flow so that's a change to the point
of attack about twice maybe three times it is
Split Second and the Kings once again lead by
one fi that pass broken up takes one for me
threw traffic snapped it on that save Lankin
in Juicy Rebound in front McDavid Backes
an end he set up the initial pressure and
then he finishes the effort here by McDavid he
claws through a couple Nashville Predators gets
the first shot on that and then it's McDavid
that picks it up and elevates in tight just
a tremendous job to bank it off the back of
lanolin and put it into the net that was by
Design Crosby the Tang quickly across
Pon back for Crosby back here three T
they score it starts with s gets it back
to Chris matang they go D to D how about
that bullet pass by Marcus Paris look at this
the spinorama back hand right onto the tape
of Jake gel folks you are witnessing magic
that is incredible the vision the Precision
of Sydney Crosby and Jake was waiting
for Jake knew what they was going to
do AO loost the puck top bounce Caufield in celd
SC what a goal turn over here by Eng ball and
Coffield goes to work put on your dancing shoes
stick handle stick handle attack the triangle
by buluk and then power to the far side of the
net he may be smaller but when he gets to no the
net look at it just explodes through the check
and var's hands oh my goodness through it pun
mckinon high slot Nathan McKinnon shoots scor
you have got to be kidding me I can't believe
it what a shot from Nathan McKinnon Andreas
England kicks it right back to drewed who
there puts it over to McKinnon and just snaps a
knuckler seven all right off the inside of the
Blocker of kin out to the line to petrangelo
and across to Martinez R TI to the safe line
and rebound put home barers sh on the One Hand
That Swing watch the effort deflection by wall
and the second effort by barbashev as he Dives
across sliding reaching one arm on his stick and
able to get that puck through the pads allons
per 25th of the lead McDavid Hopkins crosses D
McDavid d one score tick tack toll into the back
of the net beautiful little fake he's going to
shoot I mean lanolin has to respect the fact
that mdavid can take that puff to the net he's
got an open Lane and he finds his number one
target he knows exactly where Dy tile is and
he buries it unable to clear held in Kopitar
feeds the middle shot score Adrien campe set
up by anj copar copar puts that pass soft he
doesn't want to force K into pulling a trigger
he doesn't want to so he makes the pass a little
bit softer you saw what kempi had to do he had to
go down to one knee but he could time it King's
tap one nothing lead he's he scor right off the
draw Doris pushes it over and Brady K Chuck just
musle man itself through two guys right there he
turns and then as he's going down walks the pace
that opens up space on that far side where he goes
he uses his long range a good quick shot there
before SOS can get in complete position game
time
yes